[Music]
Haidee used to be my little buddy go on
nature hikes skip rocks we used to be so
connected hey Dad
smile you know you can experience things
a whole lot better without that care dad
this is how I experience it I don't
think tomorrow I'm finally leaving for
college but in the meantime I made you
guys this goodbye Vidya you know what
this is our last night together how
about we make 10 seconds of family eye
contact
starting with your phone down now no
you're allowed to blink it's just my
contacts oh no screams at the table then
why are you kicking me I don't
understand I'm just look I'll watch it
dad it's too late look I want to watch
it dad this is exactly why I'm excited
to leave too much lady I know you can
fix this
[Music]
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport I canceled your plane ticket
to college
we are gonna drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family hey
Dad can you check the trunk yeah sure
thank you Katie
the kids are supposed to be some great
idea this is someone we hear a pal bout
to drop her biggest invention yet meet
the helper thing we promise you they
will never turn either mom what is that
greetings humans technology rising up
sayonara robots roaming the streets what
is this strange creature dog Pig dog dog
loaf of bread maybe just have always
been weird they come to wash your hands
don't worry I never do that's what makes
us great then we just might be weird
enough to save the world all right hands
in
[Music]
you